hey guys in this video i'm gonna give
you my 20 best gift ideas for women now
of course we know that every single
woman in this world is unique your
girlfriend
or wife
your sister
your mother your grandmother or even
just a friend but i'm sure that you'll
find a perfect gift in this video so
let's not waste any more time let's get
right to it
[Music]
all right guys now if it's the first
time that you're here i want to welcome
you to dlm men's lifestyle my name is
daniel and if you haven't subscribed yet
please consider it so you won't miss any
of the future videos now let's start
with the first gift idea
chocolate
now almost every woman that i know loves
chocolate but don't just get her just
normal chocolate get her something
special so that she will feel special
like this could diva chocolate box
or this lint gift box
kindle if she loves reading and this is
a no-brainer because then she'll have
all her books
in one place
a hair care set every woman loves a hair
care set i mean even your grandmother
will love it so get her the healthy hair
essentials kid from olaplex i'll add a
few more options for you in the video
description down below
a smart tablet if she's into electronics
and cool gadgets then you can get her a
smart table lamp that changes brightness
color and warmth with her voice or with
her phone i mean that's cool you can get
one from huguai
or phillips
a purse organizer i personally think
every woman needs a first organizer
because have you looked at a woman's
purse i mean
it's there's always a lot of stuff in
there and they just keep on pulling
stuff out so get her a nice purse
organizer like this one
again i'll add a few products for you in
the video description and they're direct
links as well so it's just easier for
you to go and check it out
now while we are talking about our
handbag
if she's got an old one get her a new
one
or if she loves going to the gym why not
just get her a new gym bag that can
replace the old one
[Music]
next up is a facial steamer now most
women they love going to the spa right
if they can afford it but why not get
her something that she can use at home
like this facial steamer from ira ionic
or this professional one from pure daily
care
another cool idea is a food massager
this is a perfect gift for any woman
imagine this most of them or a lot of
women that i know wear high heels so
they get back from work they come home
they tire their feet
painful and then there you are the food
massager hello this is a nice one from
miku shiatsu
[Music]
bath salt most women enjoy a good bath
so it'll be just so much more special
with good quality bath salt in it if you
get them this one from murthy and
daughters it comes in a nice package as
well that you love
cartier perfume i have never met any
woman that doesn't love good perfume
that doesn't love to smell good or if
you're married why not get her a monthly
subscription from sandberg it will allow
her to choose a different perfume every
month to try out
just remember i'll add all the details
in the video description down below
she loves coffee get her a temperature
control mug this is a good idea
especially for the day that we live in
you know we've covered and all these
lockdowns going on well most of it has
passed but most people still work from
home and they love their coffee so why
not get her this smart mug to keep her
coffee warm or actually you can get her
something that's even better check out
this retro coffee maker from nostalgia
adjustable wrist and ankle weights if
she loves working out she'll love this
jewelry every woman loves jewelry but of
course here it depends on the woman
because
you need to get her something that fits
in with her taste so you need to really
know the person that you're buying
jewelry for a lot of few good options
for you in the video description down
below
nice plant
it's always good to have something green
in the house and most women they love
plants
especially because it makes the
atmosphere in the house so much better
get her something for her hobby you just
need to know what she likes to do for
example if she loves crochet then get
her a nice crochet kit or if she likes
painting her nails all the time get her
a led nail lamp
most women will start to talk about
their hobbies anyway when you just show
a little bit of interest so keep your
ears out
a gift set of spices now of course this
is only gonna work if she loves cooking
for example this spice willa gift set
has 18 unique spices that she would
probably love to use in her next meal
then of course you can join her at lunch
and dinner so it's a win-win
a bread maker
now let me tell you this is not just a
gift for women but also for men i mean i
have a bread maker here at home and let
me tell you nothing beats that smell of
fresh bread
in the morning
a luxury tea gift box she loves tea then
get her some special tea not just normal
tea at the grocery store but special tea
being a south african here in south
africa we have a specialty called ruebos
translation red bush is really good
because it doesn't have any caffeine in
it it is healthy super healthy and if
she struggles to sleep this is going to
be great because it calms her body down
as well check it out in the video
description
an instant camera now i'm not sure that
every woman will like this but i'm sure
that most young women will love it this
is cool because it captures a moment in
time and it can give you the photo
immediately
alright guys the bonus tip
and this is the best tip that you can
get any woman out there in the world
and it is
your love
you need to make her feel loved and very
important appreciate it
if you already do that then any other
gift that you will get her will just
mean so much more to her
now if you need any other gift ideas for
men check out this video here and i'll
see you there and always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys